you
before we go in we want to share
something to make your day a little
brighter and better Home Depot employees
worked overtime to help a little boy in
Georgia two year old Logan Moore was
born with hypotonia the muscle disorder
affects motor skills and makes it
difficult to walk his parents worried
that insurance would not cover a walker
so they went to a home depot in
Cedartown Georgia last week to buy parts
to build one themselves when employees
heard Logan's story they surprised his
parents building the walker for them
free of charge Logan's father said the
family was overwhelmed oh it means so
much because I'm ready for him to be
running around and wearing me out you
know trying to keep up with him and this
is just the first day of Justin Walker
said just Moore said the Walker has also
given his son a new independence alright
once again it shows you kindness always
works so they heard about it and on
their own they do
nicely done Home Depot volumes about the
people they're actually I hope you buy
the trees everything it's the America we
know in the